a new sort of Iron Curtain us to send it
across Europe offence costing millions
of euros its purpose is to keep people
out people seeking refuge in the EU
people like Magette Abbas his wife Basu
and their children Kurds from northern
Syria they've been living in Bulgaria
for almost a year now they escaped war
and violence landed in abject poverty
thinks what you had you know what
children could not sleep at night having
some call could not want them we've got
two too many things what those people
have been getting they are easily go to
the Germany because they have money
what Bulgaria the poorest European Union
member does not have the money to handle
the influx it's lunchtime at a refugee
camp on the outskirts of the capital
Sofia according to EU guidelines warm
meals are to be provided to all refugees
within the EU but Bulgaria simply
doesn't have the resources even if
conditions are improving
you put Oprah dear luck with you almost
a year ago we didn't have hot meals yeah
well she talked now we have hot meals
and the difference is tremendous yeah he
lost look at this testing over on them
this old school is being thoroughly
renovated soon it'll have a kitchen of
its own some small consolation for the
refugees here I have no idea either
school
my dad Arbaaz hopes to come to Germany
or somewhere else in Western Europe like
most of his fellow refugees but he can
only do so illegally volunteer program
coordinator Denis so such ever has to
explain that this is the only way
refugees have been able to make it to
the west
they say that there are proximately 200
people now in this camp they used to be
over 800 and now everybody wants to go
everybody wants to go to escape the more
they want to be free to travel
EU legislation states that all refugees
must remain in the first GU country they
enter but that places the greatest
burden on the countries along the e
u--'s land borders so Bulgaria has
little motivation to stop refugees from
heading west illegally but it's highly
motivated to stem the inward flow of
refugees as here in el chavo near the
borders to Greece and Turkey
stoian Stoyanov is the marshal at the
Bulgarian border post here his patrol
men intercept most of the refugees
sneaking across from Turkey
amid ah hemoglobin with the most active
time is usually just after dawn under
cover of darkness they move to the
border and cross at dawn Rani please
print but of course this is not a good
strategy
beautiful ostrich quail and Pathan opens
now cameras can see everything during
the day and night doctor visit but is
not the coverage of the producer the EU
provided millions of euros to help
Bulgaria secure its border much of it
went for this high-tech fortification
story Arnold's cameras keep a close
watch on every metre of the border with
the non-eu member Turkey one way to deal
with the crisis in July Bulgaria
completed the primary component of its
barrier and border surveillance system a
fence topped with razor wire it took
nine months to put up the 30 kilometer
long three meter high fence
25 years ago the Iron Curtain on this
line between the former Eastern Bloc
member Bulgaria and NATO member Turkey
was torn down at 20 honest officers
reservist has nothing to do with the
Iron Curtain only a facility of 30
kilometers on the border between
Bulgaria and Turkey
a very effective facility now it's
virtually impossible for anyone to make
it through this section of the border in
this rugged terrain refugees used to be
able to hide at both ends of the fence
Bulgarian border patrol men stand ready
to stop anyone trying to go around the
fence all routes across the border are
sealed trailer trucks are also searched
for people trying to sneak across the
border a high-tech device is used to
analyze the air for traces of the
presence of human beings the traffickers
take upwards of 1,000 euros for each
person they smuggle across the border to
Bulgaria the fence is likely to drive
the prices up to get to the west costs
twice as much if they don't get caught
here my Jed Abbas feels like he's caught
in limbo he's not allowed to travel on
to his relatives in Western Europe and
he's not welcome in Bulgaria they are
still us go go from here they said to us
go from here and they made too much
trouble for us just to give us out from
Bulgaria
the Western EU members are now tree
thinking the policy of sending illegal
refugees back to Bulgaria some even a
few who've already been sent back here
may possibly soon be legally heading
west